[Music]
heads up nick fury's calling you
that's him you sent nick fury to
voicemail i gotta go you do not
ghost nick fury hey how's it hanging
i love that guy i need a suit
i like the new suit thanks
hello peter hello would you like to see
what i can do
whoa
it's a hard path a life of a hero
[Music]
people depend on you
even if you win a battle
sometimes they die
i got to get you guys out of here you're
on the jet who are you i work with
spider-man you work for spider-man
i work with spider-man not for
spider-man
new plan
hi everyone we have a whole bunch of new
spider-man far from home trailer footage
to break down a couple
really big scenes some big easter eggs
too and rumors about what's going on
with norman osborne in the marvel
cinematic universe so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the marvel videos it's gonna be
crazy this summer we're doing a new
round of the infinity gauntlet giveaway
too all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a spider-man
comment on the video
i'll start with the brand new footage
first talk about a couple of the
conspiracy theories that i think are
going on because they hid a couple
things in this trailer they purposefully
removed a couple things
or swapped in some temporary footage so
that you don't know what's actually
happening in the final version of the
movie we start with that same scene with
the crusher hogan fight poster from the
original toby maguire spider-man movie
this is after that big conference that
he gives we've already learned that
they've changed that because in the
original version of the trailer he's in
the stark tech suit giving everyone the
thumbs up
but we now know in the final version of
the scene he's wearing the iron spider
outfit so already think about all the
other stuff that they could have changed
in the trailer to mislead you so that
you don't see what's actually happening
you all remember crusher hogan from the
first tobey maguire spider-man movie
that was played by macho man randy
savage in real life he was fighting him
in the cage to just try and earn money
the amazing spider-man
[Music]
you're going nowhere i got you for three
minutes
there's a much longer version of the
scene with him taking down the man
freddy mobsters when he's wearing the
iron spider outfit in that restaurant
the police shout about how much they
love spider-man
just the idea that the neighborhood
loves spider-man friendly neighborhood
spider-man
just wait till j jonah jameson debuts in
the marvel universe and start
posting hit pieces on him in the daily
bugle just trashing him in the press
there's a much longer high-res version
of the scene of him making his new steve
ditko spider-man suit on the back of
iron man's jet
i need a new suit cue secret door
opening in the back of the jet to reveal
iron man's lab technology in the
fabrication device
really cool printer for making new
spider-man outfits or complicated
european espresso machine you decide but
don't you wonder how long this stuff has
been
on the back of this jet because they
flew on this jet back during captain
america civil war when happy took him to
germany and they gave him the first
version of the stark tech suit
so this lab could have been here this
entire time there's a really huge easter
egg in this shot for the comic book iron
spider suit the red gold one
when he's trying to decide what kind of
a new suit to make this is probably part
of a larger easter egg scene where the
machine has designs for hundreds of
different spider-man suits from the
comics maybe a whole bunch of them just
flash on screen really quickly when he's
trying to decide what the new suit is
going to look like
this might be a scenario whereby the new
steve ditko spider-man suit winds up
being a combination
of the iron spider suit in the old stark
tech suit because it does look almost
exactly like the other stark tech suit
otherwise why wouldn't he just print the
exact same suit clearly there's some
function that the new one has to serve
but if you look at the other ones on the
display here you have the old stark tech
suit up at the top here
there's a third one down here that
actually seems like it could be a
combination of the red gold iron spider
suit and the old stark tech suit
so maybe this is him just mixing and
matching things from previous suits to
make the new one
this also makes me think that his
gauntlet display here he has on his arm
has something to do with deploying the
new suit or at least controlling some of
this technology
but it might be just leftover gauntlet
technology from the iron spider outfit
from avengers infinity war in avengers
end game
it's a little hard to read what's going
on on all these displays in really great
detail so this could have something to
do with him fabricating the new suit or
it could just be more data on molten man
helping him find a weakness and how to
fight him
happy just casually complimenting
spider-man on a shiny new suit while
he's holding on to the exterior of the
cockpit mid-flight
no big deal they're just traveling super
fast mid-air
then they have that brand new funny tag
scene of him using iron man's special
glasses like you notice he opens up the
case it says stark tech
puts them on and they start talking to
him but
the voice doesn't sound like anybody
you've ever heard before and it actually
sounds kind of lame
so conspiracy theory when this heads up
display opens up and says would you like
to see what i can do
the real voice when we go to see the
movie will be a character that we know
maybe it'll be karen
suit lady maybe it'll be friday the
voice of iron man's ai
or maybe a long shot maybe it could be
robert downey jr's voice as tony stark
speaking to him in
ai form just to be clear though if they
are pulling a big surprise like that
that doesn't mean that tony stark is
still alive it just means that he used
his voice
to create a new artificial intelligence
he'd just be talking to his own version
of jarvis that sounded like tony stark
but as you see the heads up display pop
up you see what the glasses actually do
they just allow
spider-man to read what other people are
texting on their phones so the glasses
themselves are hacking
everyone's phones telling him what
they're communicating about jb smoove's
character is reading a history of
witchcraft he's one of the chaperones on
the trip
they actually put him in this movie
after he did the audi
car ad during the last movie when they
were marketing it he wasn't a character
in spider-man homecoming
they just did a funny car ad with
spider-man having to take his driver's
test and he was the proctor of that exam
in real life kevin feige and the
director thought that that was so funny
that
performance that they had to put him in
the next movie so that's how jb
smoove wound up being a character in
spider-man far from home i see that
i notice everything peter
bad guys so i pass
but a history of witchcraft is a book in
real life so they're just trying to make
his character seem more interesting like
wow he's really interested in reading
about the history of witchcraft martin
starr's mr harrington character
obviously
mostly there for comedic relief is
texting someone saying
looks like things are looking up finally
some good luck
big surprise though this is probably
right before something really terrible
happens to everyone on this tour bus
because mr harrington is a character has
the worst luck of any character in the
marvel cinematic universe
everywhere he goes with these kids on
every single trip there's always a huge
disaster
one of his other classmates is texting
his mother asking her to wire him more
money
and then notice the blank chat bubble up
at the top here
this is the character that everyone
thinks is secretly playing the chameleon
working with mysterio why would they
purposefully remove
what he's talking about from the trailer
because it should be popping up here in
text form
probably because it's something super
spoilery because this seems like it's
happening a little bit later in the
movie
but the director did say that earlier
during this scene here he shows up in
the secret base
working for nick fury on his team or
seemingly working for nick fury
this is him in the background of this
mysterio scene working on something
different
so no coincidence that he shows up on
this tour bus here
that they just have the funny moment of
ned leeds and his new girlfriend betty
brant texting each other being an
annoying couple like ah
can't believe those two the really cool
norman osborne rumor now
is that he really is going to be one of
the post-credits scenes and will show up
as the actual person who bought the
avengers tower from tony stark as
oscorp is one of the few entities in the
marvel cinematic universe with enough
money
to pay for this crazy expensive
manhattan real estate
you're talking like 70 hundred million
dollars just to buy the stark tower
because of where it exists in manhattan
so you'd have to be super rich or a
giant company in order to be able to
afford it
if they did something like that at the
end of the movie that would imply that
kevin feige has bigger plans for norman
osborne in the marvel cinematic universe
aside from just being
a really big spider-man villain a much
bigger avengers level villain
there have been rumors about them
working on a thunderbolt project for a
long time now
it would make sense that they're
introducing a lot more cool bigger
villains in the marvel cinematic
universe as a path to that like you
populate the universe
with a bunch of bigger sort of
second-tier villains that you could put
on a thunderbolts team eventually
that's why they don't always kill the
villains off and why i don't think that
they're going to kill mysterio at the
end of spider-man far from home
because jake gyllenhaal is such a huge
actor mysterio is such a classic
spider-man film
why would you rush to kill him off right
after you introduce him when you can
always bring him back in another movie
for some hardcore sinister 6
action or if they want to do a dark
avengers spin like a dark
rain storyline within the marvel
cinematic universe but that would be a
much
bigger thing than just doing a solo
spider-man film that's why characters
like doctor doom are so important going
into marvel phase 4 and phase 5 although
i don't think we're gonna see dr doom in
the universe till marvel phase five
you need villains that can operate on
the level of tony stark iron man and
norman osborne
can be or at least he could be a dark
version of tony stark
billionaire industrialist but none of
the morality none of the drive to be a
hero
brilliant but the overriding vision that
his
ideas are the best ideas his way is the
best way for the world
so like tony stark wanted to wrap the
world in a suit of armor
and that was an example of him taking
things too far that's how you got to the
iron legion to ultron being created so
tony stark stepping over the line winds
up having dire consequences
think about what would happen if you
have someone like norman osborne who's
just as brilliant
but has none of the drive to be a hero
here's my big question for you guys
though if they do
introduce norman osborne in a bigger way
in the marvel cinematic universe
and they wind up keeping him around like
not killing him off so that he could be
a villain for an avengers movie
do you actually want them to do a dark
rain type of story
if you never read dark rain in the
comics what happened is is you have like
a series of big comic book events
you have marvel's comic book civil war
it destabilizes the world leaving it
ripe for invasion they do the secret
invasion storyline where all the scrolls
come in
and what happens is is norman osborne
winds up taking credit for getting rid
of the scrolls at the end of that
storyline so he's put in a position of
power by the us government tony stark
has to go on the run
so norman osborn co-opts all of tony
stark's technology and his resources
to become the iron patriot so it's a
very different type of spin on norman
osborne
someone rising to power in the vacuum
left by tony stark
like spider-man keeps saying in the
trailer the world is looking for the new
iron man
there are villains contending for that
title too thinking that they have a
claim to the throne
but a lot of that is still speculation
it just depends on how they want to use
the norman osborne character and if they
want to use the norman osborne character
so if we get any more details about that
or plans for sinister six that we hear
about i'll totally do a video about it
it's gonna be coming out in a month so
we won't have to wait that long to find
out what's really going on
fox let me see x-men dark phoenix i'm
allowed to post my non-spoilery review
later tonight at like 10 p.m but because
that's gonna be way too late i'll just
post it in the morning so as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll see the video when i post it i'll
do easter eggs post credit scene for
dark phoenix later this week after it
actually hits theaters so no worries
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big marvel video
wayne cautious please email me on the
about page of my channel so i can get
your details
click here for my teaser video on the
new avatar the last airbender netflix
series that's coming
and click here for my avengers endgame
hulk ending scene and deleted scenes
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you